I'm fed and her family have been living
in this classroom since April last year
they were rescued along with other
families by the Red Crescent when the
wall reach it the aims are a
neighborhood in southern Tripoli the
family missed their old house where they
each had their own room now they all
have to sleep cook and sit in this room
the Hylian watching hunt our old house
was ransacked and burnt down and we
became homeless who can make it up for
us I paid a lot of money to build it we
have no interest in this war no one
feels our suffering we've paid a lot for
this war more than 150,000 people have
flipped their homes in southern Tripoli
since forces loyal to the warlord
Khalifa Haftar moved on the capital the
internationally recognized government
says it's determined to defend the city
international mediation has failed to
put an end to the conflict development
projects have been halted by the war
many schools have been turned into
makeshift camps some have sheltered in
these abandoned they have built
apartments with no electricity or
running water the displaced families
here say they used to go out in the city
almost every day to have a relief from
the school atmosphere now with the first
announcement of coronavirus pandemic and
tripoli they have locked themselves up
in the school classrooms which is adding
to their agony health workers have been
trying to help people in the shelter's
by sanitizing the rooms and giving them
detergents we're keen to not only stress
on personal sanitation of the families
but also to raise their awareness about
potential infection and how to take
measures to prevent it with the holy
month of Ramadan approaching
more tough days await those who live
here being together is the only solace
they have for now Mahmoud Abdul Wahid al
jazeera Tripoli